plus d'un mois après la proposition de
bruno le maire les incertitudes
demeurent
la prime semble toujours sur la table
mais c'est sur son montant que l'on
s'interroge en outre le nombre de
salariés qui seront en mesure de la
touche et n'a toujours pas été précisée
il y a deux philosophies en fait faut-il
récompenser davantage celui qui bosse le
plus d'heures à temps complet qui a donc
été peut-être plus exposés aux risques
par rapport à celui qui est à mi temps
ou faut-il considérer que le risque est
le même pour tous que ce soit à mi temps
ou à temps complet
certaines entreprises se sont ainsi
prononcés et ont choisi de récompenser
en priorité et salariés à temps plein
les primes seront ensuite calculée au
prorata des heures effectuées
pourtant bon nombre d'enseignants
affirme qu'elle ne se sont pas engagés à
verser une somme d'un tel montant ce que
regrette olivier guivarch secrétaire
général de la fédération des services
cfdt
après les premières déclarations on
assiste ainsi à une sorte de revirement
des dirigeants qui ont été rattrapés par
des considérations financières
chaque enseigne met en place des
modalités complexes pour faire en sorte
de verser moins des questions en suspens
qui devront pourtant trouver des
réponses
le rendez vous est pris pour le 30 avril
prochain date à laquelle les modalités
exactes du versement des primes doivent
être communiqués pour renversement en
mai